foreign
[Music]
good evening yesterday a scathing report
into parties in Downing Street over
lockdown today a raft of cost of living
measures announced by the chancellor
we've waited five months for the full
sugary reports and it didn't hold back
the document detailed a casual
disregards for the rules during the
lockdowns and the Prime Minister was
forced to apologize but it comes at a
time of struggle of economic hardship
for much of the country and so the
pressure was on the chancellor today to
ease that pain but do they understand
are the Tories as many say they are out
of touch cabinet minister Jacob Reese
mogg has led a privileged life and he's
not afraid to speak his mind let's see
what he has to say
also ahead the story of Darren he
struggled during lockdown with work and
turned to Crime as a source of income
but paid the ultimate price being badly
burnt after he was electrocuted he's now
awaiting world-fast surgery and has a
message for people who might consider
taking the same path
plus it's a drama following a family of
divorce lawyers with four women as the
main characters and you'll be hard
fetched to find people who haven't been
gripped by it we speak to the director
and one of the lead actors of the split
Jacob rees-mork is one of the best known
and most controversial figures in this
government a Hardline brexiteer his
views often divide opinion and he always
speaks his mind he's now a cabinet
minister and so has unique access to
government decisions a government under
pressure of party Gate scandal and a
cost of living crisis and with a big
announcement from the chancellor today I
spoke to him about what that means for
the country but also about what drives
him in politics
Jacob riesmock thanks so much for
talking to me today I really appreciate
it and I've got lots to talk about
there's lots going on in the news uh
about uh the Sue gray report the cost of
living but first I wanted to talk a
little bit about you and your political
Outlook
um and there's lots of things about you
viewers might not know that you were a
hugely or are a hugely successful
investment banker before you came into
politics uh you married into wealth you
and your
wife Helena have six children you're a
devout Roman Catholic yours is a very
fortunate and fulfilled life
so why politics
um a number of reasons one is that if
you have been very fortunate in life
you might feel that you've got a duty to
do something about it if you've got the
opportunity to do it so that's the sort
of Pious reason but there's then the
fact that it is enormously and
captivatingly interesting so I enjoy
doing it but I also think I have an
element of Duty to do it and just in
terms of your political career you are
in cabinet you're one of the most
well-known faces actually I would argue
of the conservative party often it's
quite difficult for politicians to get
cut through but you do have cut through
but you've also become a touch paper a
bit if you don't mind me saying at times
and you're you're a divisive politician
sometimes that lots of people really
really like you but you also come in for
quite a lot of criticism that does it
surprise you and why do you why do you
think that is oh well I think if you're
in politics you must expect that people
will disagree with you and will disagree
with you strongly on important issues so
if you take brexit brexit was very
divisive for for the country and people
who are in favor of it really wanted to
get our independence back well that was
fundamentally important people on the
other side of the argument felt in some
cases that something they had worked for
their whole political careers was being
removed and were very upset about that
so if you're in politics surely you want
to put forward your views you want to
put them forward as clearly as possible
and then you're going to find people
disagree with you you could be a limb
Dam and say whatever people want here
and then you hate that nobody will
either like you or dislike you that
doesn't seem to be a lot of point in
that and before I get on to what type of
conservative you are just just to finish
off in this idea of the divisiveness
which you acknowledge does it does it
bother you I mean I saw that you heckled
at a university uh during brexit I think
your family were bothered while they
were with you do you just see that as
the ugly underbelly of politics or do
you actually think that it's a kind of
corrosive aspect of public life does it
upset you when you personally experience
things like that no because I'm a great
believer in freedom of speech right and
I think that nearly made me go into
public life your opening question was
why did I do it I have decided to go
into public life therefore people are
entitled to disagree with me and they're
entitled to disagree with me forcefully
and they are entitled to wave Banners at
me as long as it isn't physical
intimidation I think it is perfectly
legitimate for politicians to face argue
argument about what they believe in
Steve Bray is entitled to stand in the
middle of the road and Shout nonsense
all day long because that's what he
believes in and that's freedom of speech
and I do worry actually that we don't
protect freedom of speech as much as we
ought to in this country and what type
of conservative are you
um what type of conservative am I
well I believe in Freedom of the
individual the starting point and most
things flow from that that I believe
that it's people's own money not the
government's money and therefore people
should be entitled to keep their own
money as far as possible low tax low tax
that they should make decisions about
their own lives with as little
interference from the status is
practical State a small states yes would
you like to see
a more closer link between
the church and the state between
politics and the church or do you think
that these things should remain separate
I think we've got it about right in this
country I'm not an Anglican but I like
the fact that the Anglican Church is the
established church it maintains a place
for God within our Civic Society so
remembrance Sunday the Anglican Church
leads it there will be the service for
70 hours of the Queen's Reign the
Platinum Jubilee that will be led by the
Anglican Church I think the position of
the Archbishop of Canterbury is a is a
very important one and I it's no
surprise you 100 with a great admire of
the archbishops I think he is a good and
holy man even when he makes political
interventions because he gets very
criticized by many of your colleagues
when he does that I think you can admire
and respect people even when they say
things that you would rather they didn't
say so this doesn't mean I adopt all his
political views it may mean they
disagree strongly with them but I think
he is
um Force for good in society and I think
he's a genuinely holy man actually do
you think he should be allowed to say it
though I believe in freedom of speech
the reason I ask is that many of your
colleagues I I there was a recent
example
and a number of your colleagues I think
you might have been critical about the
Prime Minister around the party gate
issue I think that might have been I
can't quite remember a number of your
colleagues were maybe in the borders
border policy yeah forgive me the Border
policy he was very critical of what
wasn't he and a lot of your colleagues
said that this was inappropriate and
actually there was a bit of a pile on
towards the Archbishop you don't agree
with being silenced in that way he must
make his own statements
um and must be free to say what he wants
I didn't agree with him but I went to
the Cardinal Archbishop Westminster
Vincent Nichols
um homily at the red Mass which is the
master begin the legal year and he stood
in the Paul Peters absolutely
magnificent sermon he gave he said look
you're very important judges and you'll
judge all these important cases
but don't forget there's a higher judge
who will judge you one of these days and
so if I like it when cleric say things
that make people sit up and think when I
agree with them I shouldn't be too
squeamish when they say things that make
people sit up and think that I don't
agree with that's reasonable and and
Jacob just on another
it's called past you
there's one more thing on this Roe
versus Wade I was interested in this
about what you might have felt about
this it was the landmark legislation
that legalized abortion across it wasn't
legislation sorry antique it was a case
that's right it was a case that the
Supreme Court ruled on but my pedantry
is very important because that wasn't
democratically decided and that seems to
me to have been the the source of all
the trouble whereas this country decided
it I'm sorry sorry no no that's that's
absolutely
completely fine
um but you wouldn't want to ban abortion
there's no Prospect for Parliament
voting to ban abortion but I think the
numbers
are just the saddest aspect of modern
British life
the saddest the sad
200 000 babies that aren't born this is
this is so sad desperate this loss of
life that would otherwise be created I
think is desperately sad
now we were just talking you are a small
state low tax conservative today a 37
billion pound package just announced by
the chancellor
is it your view that the public
particularly following covert are now
too reliant on the government and the
state to solve problems that this pack
it's just when does it stop
well
this is in a way a continuation of the
covid problem I was very strongly in
support of the furlough scheme and other
schemes like that because the government
is there when everything else is
collapsing and if the government hadn't
provided furlough hadn't provided loans
to businesses but we would have had no
economy to come back to when things
reopened
and that would have been even more
inflationary than what we've currently
got currently the disruption supplies
change made worse by war in Ukraine made
worse
by the rise in fuel prices
um is an Aftershock of covid very much
like the aftershocks that you get with
with an earthquake and the government
cannot leave people completely unable to
pay their fuel bills so the state has a
role David Davis and John red were just
in the chamber have warned already about
inflationary risks about today's
measures do you see their concerns do
you share them I see their concerns and
as I say I think this is a bouncing act
that it would be foolish of me to
pretend it's easy to to get right
and on another let's just get through
the measures that you just now he's also
announced his temporary level on the
profits of oil and gas companies at a
rate of 25
or but in name a windfall tax you've
been openly against a windfall tax
haven't you well
um importantly it is not retrospective
retrospective taxation is to my mind
entirely improper that people must be
taxed on what they know is going to come
so that's an important change but if you
you don't sound that you it's not you
it's Collective response
you support government policy but have
you changed your mind because you were
against it but this is what I said to
you earlier I think Collective
responsibility is fundamentally
important and that ministers
are right to argue for what they believe
in private yes and then accept the
conclusion when it comes out
yeah they can textualization I'm trying
to give is that these are not easy
decisions it is a balance it is really
important to protect people and help
people who would simply have no money if
the fuel price increase went up and they
received no help and pensioners as well
and and the welfare state does have an
obligation to look after people in that
position but how you then pay for it
well is one tax better than another tax
well I was actually uh well actually
let's come to that then because um I had
something that I I wanted to ask you
about that which is um
as a wealthier person in society as I am
as well do you think that we have
wealthier people a moral duty to help
people that are less well-off whether
that's through taxation so wealthier
people pay more or through philanthropy
of course I do I mean there's to go back
to the discussion we were having on
religion this is one of the fundamental
tenets of of Christianity
big stand well you you should love thy
neighbors thyself
um the the parable of the Good Samaritan
um who is my neighbor well everybody is
my neighbor so there there is a
responsibility to help others in society
does that alarm you I was looking today
uh
two million people in the UK need to use
food banks one in five people according
to you gov this morning now say they're
struggling to or unable to make ends
meet that's a 10 rise on last year and
half of households say their financial
situations deteriorated in the last year
yeah alone it's quite worrying isn't it
it is very worrying inflation is
terribly worrying because inflation hits
the least well of most that's why the
chancellor has been doing what he has
been doing today it's why the sport
packages are very important and the
difficulty with our current welfare
system is that some benefits are
upgraded retrospectively so if you have
a year of inflation you get the
outbreaking in the
um April of the following year on the
September figure now over a multi-year
period that balance is out but in an
individual year when inflation is
running at a rapid rate that is really
difficult for people which is why the
chancellor is that that's right it's
bringing forward a help that otherwise
myself so you would even though you sort
of philosophically ideologically might
not be in favor of increased taxation
increased spending to support people at
this moment in time because of
inflationary pressure you're okay with
it basically well it also it depends on
what you mean by increased expenditure
because how are you judging this
expenditure but you'll bring in I mean
bringing forward benefits it's just
moving the money for
if inflation is running at 10 and you
have
a GDP growth which is always real terms
growth of zero the government still has
expenditures of central GDP if it
remained flat would be reduced
proportionately so in an inflationary
time there is money that is available in
a strange way that wouldn't otherwise be
available whilst keeping expenditure
level proportionate to GDP you then have
to ask yourself the question as does
that expenditure risk becoming more
inflationary itself yeah I think saying
that supporting the least well-off is
inflationary as a mistake I think you
may need to look at other areas of
expenditure but you surely want to help
those who are absolutely squeezed first
by inflation but the other big news this
week is Sue Gray's report you said in
March concerns over party gate in
Downing Street with fluff and
fundamentally trivial that was in March
do you still think that having read the
report
what have we been discussing we have
been discussing inflation the fact that
some people may not be able to make ends
meet we haven't discussed Ukraine but
the whole security of the western world
has been at risk over the last few
months and I I think the
intellectual energy spent on partygate
has been completely disproportionate but
having read the report do you still
think it's trivial what happened well
I'm afraid I'm going to say the same to
you because you had an incident where
you were at a party and you apologized
for it
my resignation as well and I sent you a
message saying I hope it didn't no you
know because I thought I thought the
reaction to you was disability I didn't
think it was true it wasn't true if you
thought I'm trivial I am consistent in
my view I think the reaction to you was
disproportionate I think the reaction
over party gets disproportionate and I
think the reaction to secure stoma is
disproportionate that so many really
important things are going on uh that we
need to get on with
um the these prime minister
um got a fine for
what seemed to be one of the least
things that went on uh in Darling Street
some of them that are in the report
didn't even go on in Downing Street they
were in the cabinet office which is not
where the prime minister is the events
the Prime Minister was at were daytime
events it seems to me
too much has been made of it when so
many other important things are going on
and the Prime Minister has apologized
but Jacob just just one other follow-up
on this if you don't mind in that report
there were reports of Staff vomiting
after too much alcohol the drunken
altercation red wine on the walls
rudeness to security staff I mean well
can you imagine behaving like that at
work that the
um as I understand it the the
um vomiting in the fight were a party in
the cabinet office which is a set which
is a there's nothing about it more
broadly no I'm not asking you directly
about the Prime Minister but that's but
that's quite that's quite important
because it all relates to the prime
minister to make it clear which I think
has been that what sounds to have been
the worst incident was actually not in
Downing Street at all well there were
there was another one in down Prince
Philip's building which but looked
terrible but I'm just asking you more
broadly it must multiply you I mean do
you not find that morally torrent I
think it's absolutely disgraceful being
rude to the people who are providing
essential services in a government
building
but we know that only two elected
politicians were fined out of the 83 and
it was neither of the two elected
politicians who were rude to the staff
you know so again this is not a culture
encouraged by the Prime Minister prime
minister would never be rude to people
who were working for him just finally 74
of the public think the Prime Minister
knowingly lied that that's a problem for
like whatever the rights or wrongs was
that that is a problem for him isn't it
well I don't think that's a fair
reflection I think the Prime Minister
said what he believed to be the case now
it is really important to remember that
it is deliberately mislead Parliament we
all make mistakes you know that
sometimes you misread a figure when
you're speaking in Parliament and you
are allowed to and I have a book
Corrections on the record if one has got
a decimal point in the wrong place or
read a figure on the next line of one's
briefing that the prime minister
did not believe that the rules had been
broken and when you look through Sue
Graves report that seems to me to be
perfectly reasonable the events he was
at
were ones that when he was there were
within the rules other than other than
the one in in the cabinet office which
seems to me one where a reasonable
person could come to the conclusion that
it was a perfectly proper event and
Jacob responded so you'll say just to be
clear you just said you're saying if the
Prime Minister middle did mislead
parliaments on this stage
that's right that's right that's right
and that's crucial that's absolutely
fundamental so you think he might have
misled Parliament inadvertently because
he didn't have the information he said
no rules were broken and we now know
that rules were broken clearly so you
think he'll be exonerated by the
Privileges committee privileged
committee is is an independent committee
it wouldn't arrive for me to prejudge it
that may even be a breach of privilege
itself so I better not get into that
thank you very much my pleasure
Jacob respond they're always interesting
to talk to and if you scan this QR code
on the screen now you can watch all of
our interviews online and all of the
previous episodes of the show
stay with us because coming up next
Darren Harris and his incredible story
of how he was electrocuted and his
rehabilitation
[Music]
when the covid lockdown hit in 2020 many
families struggled for Darren work as a
scaffolder dried up and he turned to
stealing scrap metal to make money but
he paid the ultimate price suffering
life-changing third-degree Burns this is
his story and a warning it does have
pictures and a description of his
injuries
Darren thanks so much for coming to talk
to us today really appreciate it and
it's really good to see you
um
before we get into the story about what
happened to your 18 months ago can we
talk a bit about your life before 2020
your school apprenticeship you became a
scaffolder can you tell me about that
yeah basically in high school
um I was in construction and then I went
off to do a Plastering course around two
years and then halfway through the just
about 18 months two years Mark I went I
changed my trade from Plastering to
scaffolding and then become I've done
six months training course and then
engaged with a part one and then a part
two I was a fully qualified scaffolder
and basically that's what brought me up
to the obviously being a scaffolder and
then 2020 comes on lockdown
comes yeah and work slowed down for you
yeah what what happened did you get
furlough from the government what
happened with your financial
circumstances the financial struggles
where um I wasn't up to date with my tax
returns right and so I didn't get any
help with these uh self-employment Grant
I'll get any further so I was basically
throughout the lockdown period I was
struggling financially for funds
um all the building sites and everything
was shut yeah so I wasn't able to even
find work let alone commence any work so
I was just really in a struggle with it
let's talk about what happened you said
previously that as a younger man in the
past you had broken the law here and
there yeah you left that behind right
yeah so obviously in the younger days
when I was struggling for one hour I
used to help myself to a bit of scrap
out of old abandoned buildings like
places that were getting demolished and
ready for demolition so I wasn't like
harming anybody I wasn't doing anything
majorly wrong in my mind just explain is
what is scrapping because some people
wear basically basically if you've got
an old abandoned building that's getting
pulled down and demolitioned don't
demolish so yeah
um I would say when I've been on the
building sites before the site agent
said to me I said oh there's a load of
lead on there if you want to help
yourself trick it's only going to go in
the recycle inside so that's where shark
picked up from being a worker yeah being
granted access to scrap from the site
that was working on bad site manager so
sort of they sort of introduced me into
it by saying I helped sell to this but
because other people are doing it so
obviously I've picked that up it's
something I shouldn't have picked up but
obviously I picked it up and when
November 2021 I had my initial accident
I made a bad Judgment of error so do you
got just before we go into that do you
got in trouble with the police about
that in the past when you were a younger
man one or two times where I've got in a
little bit of trouble and then you stop
doing it yeah carried on with working
you're trying just a scaffold maintain
my career lockdown happens
yeah so I had no choice in order to go
back to that sort of line of work and um
and and tell us what happened that night
what happened to you
um basically I was in an old abandoned
place I believe some sort of Steel works
I believe
um and I was doing what I was doing
collecting what I could find sort of off
the ground and stuff like that and then
um there was like a bit of an electrical
control room
um and obviously I've seen the doors
wide open and stuff so I just had a bit
of a nose there and then there was like
copper bars inside the actual machine
but because of the way the land was
situated all being like disused and
defense and everything was open and
anyone who could just walk on and off
there I just presumed it was off because
I didn't see no lights I didn't hear no
noses and the doors were wide open so
it's just like just I don't know it's
just I just presumed it was off and I
could sort of have myself to obviously a
bit of extra cash yeah and within a
blink of an eye I felt my body lock up
like an initials like I don't know a
character I can't find the words to
explain it but then I basically switched
off like I don't remember anything else
apart from I was a Dane I believe I was
dead for around two minutes so maybe a
short period of time but obviously all
of a sudden I've just woke up and then
started running for my life and I heard
him remember you're on fire yeah full
and on fire so on my stomach I'm closed
I had three layers of clothing on so
after the arc flash explosion Alma close
was on fire but at this time of being in
the room I don't remember I don't just
like I remember vaguely watching the
funeral take place as stuff as it sounds
some people don't believe me but I it's
what I remember
um so obviously I've run out for me life
um I'm on fire I've obviously with the
adrenaline I was able to run faster than
the two of The Lads so and I should have
stopped really and let him put me out
but obviously I was more concerned about
getting to the main road for safety so I
got to the main road and as my friend
was on the phone to the ambulance
service set out about 26 minute wait
time
um and I'd literally at within seconds
of him being on the phone and ambulance
was passing with the blue lights on and
I've run from the car park bit where I
was and obviously in a bad way
um and to put myself in front of the
ambulance and I knew you went to
hospital you went to the Queen Elizabeth
Hospital in Birmingham um
what happened there can I think we have
some photos actually which you were okay
if we share aren't you that's um around
December I believe
um and obviously afterwards I got a
disease called folliculitis derbycons
where I lost more hair than that so as
you can see I've had in full face
completely ripped off and redone off the
skin off my legs I think the only bit of
normal skin that I managed to keep was
probably four or five inches on the back
of my neck so everything from that point
here all around the neck my face and
obviously if my arms up to the shoulder
an army stomach was completely wrapped
in that BTM material from that image
there to you today you look remarkably
well yeah I've gone a long way yeah and
a lot of people have said to me said I
see burn survive is struggling for two
three years and the face looks like
disfigured and morphed and obviously I
don't think I'm that bad considering
it's just obviously what I'm missing is
the features that make a face so the
eyebrows the tip of the nose the ears
and obviously the hairline they're the
main things that build a face and I've
lost every single one of them
and just in terms of you're in hospital
you woke up you're in a in coma for 20
23 days 27 days 27 days
when you were scrapping you obviously
didn't realize the implications of what
could happen no obviously yeah I just I
wasn't fully aware of the dangers
um and like I said obviously the doors
was open on the room that I entered
um so it's just it's just a mage of bad
Judgment of error all around what
happened with you with the police or
nothing
um the West Midlands police service they
sent police officers to me address where
I was living in Manchester at the time
where I used to live in mum and the I
was out at the mall at the time but they
asked if they've had life-changing
injuries
so obviously the room explained to Mr
jayas is that our list done something
that done to him so obviously my start
of mind I've had my punishment in a
sense now I've got the rest of my life
to live with it it must be extremely
mentally difficult for you what keeps
you get what keeps you going
um what keeps me going I'd probably
narrow it down to
be I've been blessed with a second
chance at life because I believe for
someone so like it's a miracle to
survive it so what's the story behind
that miracle for surviving such a
significant injure because I said I've
had the worst possible injury the human
body could possibly withstand have
suffered being electrocuted and I've had
an arc flash blast sent me a catapulting
across the room and I've suffered a lot
of inhalation damage due to the smoke a
gas charge and fragments of metal I'll
just rip them into bits and I just I
believe it's a miracle that they've
managed to give me a second chance at
life so that's my main I don't know I
just believe it's there's a reason and
there's a purpose for me to be here
because if there wasn't I it would have
took me it didn't take me so you have
had Suicidal Thoughts yeah I've been
I've been to the worst of suicide
recently and because something keeps
stopping there and I'm always there
forever grateful for all the surgeons
who involve saving life and you're a
walking Miracle yeah I know obviously I
have to care because of that I just I
feel like I have to do something
constructive with it instead of sitting
at home not doing anything about it I
want to be like a bit of an inspiration
to others out there who are in a crisis
so I can to sort of basically can look
at me because I had a comment of someone
someone comment on one of my pictures
our videos are done with them online and
they said um I've been overweight and
I've struggled with mental health for
many years but after reading your story
and hearing what you've got what you've
been through and it's made me realize to
pull my socks up because in a sense
obviously if I if I can go through this
then other people with no actual
injuries on the outside but they're
mentally unwell they need to look at
someone like me and think hang on a
minute if he can go to the brink and
come back and find light at the end of
the tunnel then why can't I I read that
you wanted you're thinking about whether
you become a motivational speaker do you
go to talk to kids in school you might
be thinking about setting crime I wanna
I wanna I wanna make awareness of anyone
who's doing this sort of thing like
scrapping business and not aware of the
dangers I want to make him aware of the
dangers I know what I educate him to nip
it in the bud and never to do this
because not many people get given a
chance and I want them people in a
struggle financially doing yourself
thing go to college train yourself get
educated and get a good career I mean
how are you managing though in terms of
you know we've talked a lot about the
cost of living crisis prices how are you
how are you managing or do you uh just
about just about managed I've got a bit
of family and supportive about me but it
is difficult it's a lot obviously the
money that I'm on at the moment with
benefits and stuff it's a hell of a lot
of less than what I was earning working
by a quarter do you know what I mean so
obviously it's difficult but I've just
have to manage with what I've got and
live with what I've got and find another
and also find a new career if you you
know you've gotta finders I'm still
relatively young and 29 and 13 October
so be a shame for me to sit away and
waste my life and just do nothing and
then cause pain for the people and all
sorts like I wanna I wanna do something
constructive and be an inspiration to
others that's what I want to do because
I've still got my mind like even though
the appearance has changed your body
though yeah yeah my heart's still
beating I'm still the same person as
what I was before and it's it I'm I'm
still Darren you know what I mean but
obviously I just look different
and is that hard
looking different yeah because I I think
you look great you look really well I do
considering what I've been through
obviously it's not very hard when I look
at you look in the mirror yeah because
you know what you did look like yeah so
obviously in my eyes What Hurts the Most
is obviously the face that I was born
with and the face that everybody knew me
as Darren has gone and it's never coming
back and there's no matter what I do in
the world that face will never come back
so what people remember me as is gone
and it's really disturbing to think of
that as well and it hasn't been it's not
been very long it's been 18 years so
actually as a look now this is the worst
I'll ever look
um I've not had any reconstructive
surgery yet I've not been immaculated
eyebrows on me hair transplant uh well
the main thing I'm going for at the
moment is bioprinting bio printing
technology so there's three ways of
reconstructing an air you can have a
magnetic clip-ons like a silicone or you
can have rib reconstruction where they
tamper away at your ribs and rebuild the
cartilage out the air out your ribs so
but then you're relying on a surgeon's
technique to sculpture the air but
there's a third option which just come
out relatively new and that's onesie
Universe there and a few other companies
in the world like Australia and China
are doing it so basically take your stem
cells from your body and you put some
whatever material with it and then they
can 3D print the cartilage it's a living
ink so they can you can go on pictures
of me all day the dimensions of how it
used to look and they can read they can
3D print that ASO in time
they'll reconstruct your ears to how it
used to look on a picture of me old face
what would you say to young men to
People to People struggling either with
making them ends meet struggling with
how they look how they feel about
themselves struggling with depression
what your what's your message my message
to anyone out there attempting this sort
of thing is to don't even contemplate
doing it because one it's not worth it
you can get into trouble and getting
imprisoned for it two if you do do it
and you you could end up dead or you
could end up looking like me and having
even more problems because even though I
was in a financial struggle and now that
my own issues going on before the
accident since the accident Army
problems have multiplied by a thousand
so I don't I would what I've been
through I wouldn't wish this on me worse
anyway I just wouldn't and don't finally
when you look back on that day just
before you went into that yard what
would you what would you say to yourself
now
do you turn walk away but I can turn the
clock back you know what I mean that is
something if you had a stopwatch to sort
of stop go back in time I'd love to do
that but obviously I can't physically do
that I can't change the amount of time
but all I can do is the time that I've
got left in my life and what the next
journey in the next chapter in life is
to do better and do well from it well
I'm sure you will and thank you so much
for coming and telling us your story
today I really liked meeting you I
really enjoyed it nice thank you very
much thank you Darren's incredible Story
look if you or anyone in your family is
struggling with their mental health or
having suicidal thoughts please call the
24-hour Samaritans hotline on 116 one
two three
stay with us coming up next D kopang and
Fiona button talk to me about their big
TV drama
[Music]
what was the last show you binged
watched for years now TV has been the
new Silver Screen with many Hollywood
stars choosing Television over movies
the split is one of those shows that has
captured that at-home audience including
me I spoke to the Director D coppan an
actor Fiona button who you may know as
Rose what are you doing tonight
uh
oh God uh no no it's me it's me I I've
been putting out these really confusing
Vibes I was gonna ask if your baby's
here tonight I've got a date okay right
well yes of course because you're a
normal human being
Fiona thanks so much for coming in today
to talk to me about the split
um you are to blame uh for me being very
tired at work because I binged watched
this and stayed up to three in the
morning so it's all your fault that I've
got bags of advice but it's an
absolutely brilliant uh drama about
divorce I think it's been really popular
from what you're saying in terms of how
many people have watched it but I mean I
absolutely loved it we'll get into a bit
more of of the characters and as we go
along but Dee let's start with you
because it was your debut as a director
yeah and it's been as I said really
successful were you did you expect to
get this type of reception like when you
were making it did you think this is
this is good stuff I mean every day
every day yeah especially your husband
and no I mean the response has been
extraordinary I think it's been quite
overwhelming actually I you know I knew
it was a really loved show and which is
always slightly terrifying because when
you come onto something that's the third
season and and you know how many people
love the show you feel a little bit like
you've joined the relay race and you're
doing the final like 100 meters and
you're about to be handed the Baton and
you've just got this fear of just like
just don't drop the Baton at the last
sort of hurdle but um but yeah so I
definitely felt the pressure of that but
um but you know and I obviously I knew I
knew it was special when we were
shooting it and like you know I loved
the script so much and abuscripts are
incredible and obviously to to be you
know to be working with such a great
cast I you know I hoped it would do well
but it has definitely exceeded all sort
of expectations I think it's been quite
yeah just quite amazing how well it's
been received and you didn't drop the
bat and in fact I reckon you smashed it
right she absolutely she overtook all
the like other Runners and Fiona you
your your rose in in the series you're
the the youngest daughter uh with these
two sort of power sisters but my view of
it was that you are
the kind of warmest
character really
what was it like going through the three
series because rose has a really
difficult time in the third series she
struggles with infertility and then she
loses her husband was it was it hard to
play those scenes so they I mean they
made me cry they were very emotional
yeah
um I was pretty I mean I've said it
before I was pretty intimidated by the
by the scene where she finds out that
her husband has died I mean it's like a
mixed blessing because you get that as
an actor you get like a something really
big happen to you something you know
tragedy and you're like yes you know
great I get something to get my teeth
into and then oh God actually but I've
got to do it and I've got to do it well
and I've got to do it believably and do
justice to you know viewers who have
watched it who've lost
their partners and and and then it just
is terrifying so I was terrified
um but it kind of helped in a way and
the on the subjects of divorce you you
might think of it almost as a subject of
box office poison I mean it's something
that many people go through but it's a
horrible experience yeah um but in this
series as I say in the characters are
relatable they're struggling with
problems that many people struggle with
divorce has actually been quite a
fertile subject to to tell stories about
right yeah I guess so and I mean
obviously it's you know it's a testament
to Abby's Abby's incredible writing with
this but um you know and obviously this
this was always supposed to be a three
series
um show which was always supposed to be
can you have the good divorce so
obviously that yeah that was really the
aim of it I think also she was her aim
was I think the reason why perhaps there
hadn't been many dramas about divorces
because there's always a certain amount
of Shame that's attached and so people
don't really want to talk about their
own divorce but it just so happens that
one in three marriages end in divorce
you don't have to be a family lawyer
from London in a really fancy house I
think it's it's really a look at love
and family and the messiness of life and
it doesn't really matter where you're
from or what your background but it's
you know it's yeah it's love family
relationships divorce affairs
trying to get pregnant losing a baby
it's you know it's something that
everyone is related to people and it
feels very raw as well very raw and very
real and I think that's a testament that
Abby's writing is she's just she's got
this such a way with words that it's
it's her dialogue is so real and so
relatable
the second visit in as many weeks yeah
it's just clearing out James's stuff
oh thank you
um
yeah
very efficient yes they do that yeah
must have been hard
oh um
okay no no I'm longing to get rid of
some of that stuff for ages
70s Afghan cope was never coming back in
a lot of the projects you've been
involved with be it the split Bridgeton
the crown yeah they're female lead is
that something important she worked on
projects that are predominantly about
promoting women or did it just happen by
chance I think it's it's a combination
of the two I think it's yeah it's
slightly started off by chance but I
guess it's what you're attracted to and
what you're kind of interested in and
what sort of yeah piques your interest
really but yes I am I yeah I guess
that's probably the thing that turns my
head the most but um obviously not just
exclusively on female projects in the
future but I think coming on board this
show was really exciting because it's a
really strong female team female you
know Abby Morgan female writer Creator
exec two female execs a sister pictures
who have you know very strong female
lead production company and yeah it was
all it was lots of
strong women in in great positions
making this female grip yeah female grit
as well yeah which is really rare and
for us to have a key key grip who's a
girl so yeah the whole thing in the
industry for a long time has been that
there's an absolute paucity of of women
directing films that films and and
series that there's there's women lots
and lots of women across the industry
but when it comes to those those big
those big big jobs it's been
predominantly male did do you do you
feel you get the same opportunities as
your male counterparts or maybe in the
past you didn't but it's changing I
think it's really changing I mean I I've
been quite lucky because I I sort of
came up
um
yeah I came up through the ranks and I
used to self shoot a lot and do a lot of
camera work so I've come up in in quite
a predominantly male
um area but I but I I kind of I knew my
craft and I was you know it was fine I I
never really had any issues really but I
I think there are definitely
uh more opportunities now and I think
there are some amazing women coming up
through it and obviously we're seeing
the success of so many great female
directors that that's opening doors and
you know it's that sort of sending you
know sending the elevator back down for
the others and um I feel that's that's
happening now we're approaching hard
times as a country in terms of the cost
of living
um
do you think that in a way that
people are going to want more escapism
that they're going to want more sort of
shows like this where they can just lose
themselves yeah I think
I think so you look at the success of
Bridgeton in lockdown as well that was
you know another one that is you know
total escapism I think people do love
seeing that but but with this as well it
is important although they have you know
wonderful amazing incredible lives in
very big houses and wonderful kitchens
and incredible locations that you have
good kitchens
but you know it's still they have all
the same messiness and complications as
everyone else with you know with
certainly in the family yeah and I think
I I think there has been a shift since
the pandemic though I mean I don't know
I can't speak for the entire country
obviously but like I think maybe there's
less cynicism in a way like when we with
our TV choices like we want to watch
something that has heart and is and is
isn't ashamed of that and isn't ashamed
to say like we love and we love strongly
and we feel things and talk about you
know feelings in that way in that kind
of explicit way that Abby does and just
to end
uh D which is your favorite character
company
that's not you in a minute okay but you
know gosh she's so hard it's that's
literally like asking someone to pick
their favorite child kind of but I love
you too no no it's just
but it's not that you love them all
equal it's just that you love certain
things about each of them so much and I
think you know any or any show that you
do and you probably feel the same with
the things you pick you have to love the
script you've got to really love the
project because you've got to fall in
love with every character but there's a
weird thing though where uh Ruth is
exactly like my mother it's really
strange which is always always quite
bizarre but um yeah I don't think
excluding Rose
who was your favorite who's your
favorite character carrot it's so hard
because it's hard to separate the
character from the actor now yeah right
okay so so
you know I it it's hard to be like to
talk about them without the performances
because they're so part of who they are
well let me ask you for what was your
favorite bit about playing Rose about
that oh you definitely playing with
playing with those people all the time
getting to play with
Hannah and Nina with the Nicola and
Annabelle and Debs yeah they're like the
sisters everyone wants really I thought
so thanks so much thanks Steve thanks
Jonah for coming to talk to us today
thank you very much for having us loved
it thank you thank you thank you well
that's all for today's show thank you to
all our guests D kopan and Fiona button
Darren Harris and Jacob Reese smorg and
thank you for watching
[Music]